who gets gongs after the blasting of
Boris Johnson's resignation honors
perhaps here a less contentious lineup
that's lovely fantastic recognized and
rewarded in the King's first birthday
honors Suzanne Richards now MBE she lost
her son Joel her brother and her father
in the 2015 Tunisian terror attack and
she set up a charity to help others
bereaved by murder or terrorism
never in a in a world of Sundays has
everything could get anything like this
but it is Bittersweet yeah there's a
reason why I've received this Suzanne is
already poised to help the families of
last week's Nottingham killings just
knowing what that families know what
those families are going through
um and you know it's just terrific
there's such a mirror image of what
happened they were 19 Joel was 19
student University Savage Joel so yeah
but we will be here to support them
at 18 junior frude is the youngest on
the list awarded a British Empire medal
the young dancer making moves to beat
bullying with his hashtag Boys Can Dance
it means so much like it just shows like
all the hard work I do is being noticed
and like my voice is being heard and
people are hearing me and it just feels
so crazy that I'm the youngest like it's
it's so crazy and I'm so honored to
receive this award also on the list Dame
Anna Wintour the Vogue editor-in-chief
awarded a companion of Honor as are the
author sir Ian McEwen and Professor Sir
John Bell who played a prominent role in
the pandemic there are mbes for Davina
McCall and the actor Vicki McClure who's
campaigned about dementia and an mbe2
for the footballer now pundit Ian Wright
for his services to charity and Sport
this year's list a continuation of the
coronation theme of helping out and
service the king doesn't choose who gets
honored but it is part of his first
official birthday celebrations including
his first trooping the color as king he
will make his way up the mail on
horseback the first time a Monarch's
done that since 1986.
and for that the flags are out and the
route ready with thousands expected for
another Royal spectacle Laura bundock
Sky News